we're going to begin this hour with the
start of a new era in Britain this week
with the coronation of King Charles III
the Monarch 74 years old will be crowned
on Saturday of course it's a role he's
prepared for his entire life and there's
a new documentary giving us a rare look
at his life from the people who know him
best King Charles the boy who walked
alone it's called from see it now
Studios is available right this moment
on Paramount plus it features exclusive
interviews with schoolmates and Royal
staff and never before seen photos and
stories in this preview a friend of
Camilla the queen consort discusses the
relationship between young Charles and
his mother the late Queen Elizabeth take
a look
way searched up because the the queen
became Queen very young
and as a result she missed Charles's
childhood
and there's that story he often told
about his mother coming back from very
very long tour and he rushes onto the
Royal yacht to greet her hoping for a
hug and she just holds up her hand to be
shaken
shake her sons CBS News Royal
contributor Amanda Foreman joins us now
Amanda thank you very much for being
here that's tough to hear right that's a
hard anecdote and then you also learn in
this documentary that he was bullied at
school how did the relationship with his
mother uh the the late queen and the
bullying shape him into who he is today
well you can see that by the essential
loneliness of this man who is his two
things at once he's he's actually always
had amazing Charisma and yet that
Charisma is linked to a sense of
complete isolation no one no one knows
what it's like to walk in his shoes and
that and that that comes out I think and
in his public appearances as well
it was also interesting
clearly catnip to women back in the day
you know most people have only known him
as we see him now King uh Prince Charles
King Charles very official but back in
the day he certainly had options when it
comes to ladies I was fascinated by the
women that who had spent time with him
talk to him
um in some it appeared to be very
intimate settings that they were still
all these years later guys giggly yeah
they were still giggling still Charmed
yes how do you how do you explain that
what can you tell us about that part of
his life yes because it's very hard to
imagine your grandpa as as you say
catnip and yet the girls who who who
went after him were absolutely gorgeous
because he has his Charisma and it's
coupled with this incredible niceness
it's one of the things that comes out in
this documentary is just how thoughtful
he is to people and how kind and
actually rather good about talking about
feelings it also made it clear though
that he and Camilla had something very
special very very early on that never
seemed to wane for either of them but
because she was a divorcee she wasn't
considered good enough or proper enough
for him yeah which is a shame I thought
so too it is a real shame and it's
really hard for us to imagine nowadays
that you could actually be separated
from the person that you love who
completes you and makes you you because
of tradition it just makes no sense and
and yet these two people should always
have been together we've got to talk
about what what was described in the in
the documentary as a spectacularly
dysfunctional family and that
dysfunction is on display with Prince
Harry's Memoir uh and this Rift in the
family how does King Charles heal the
family in the condition it is today
well the healing
healing talking and if they're not
talking then there's never going to be
any healing and behind the scenes there
have been attempts
not just kind of you know informal talks
but with with mental health
professionals because you know when it
gets this bad and it's this toxic you
need outside mediators to bring people
together so you say that this
coordination of King Charles is an
opportunity to reinvent himself
um why would you say it
well what what King Charles has always
had is actually very forward-thinking
views this is a man who in 1974 was
talking about diversity inclusion invite
the environments organic farming
Recycling and everyone dismissed him as
a crank so it's it's not that he needs
to change what he thinks or what he
believes in but he does need to adapt
for example I think that he should
become friends with Ryan Reynolds and
support no wrexham that that would oh I
see what you're saying yeah that would
kind of make him more in touch with you
know how people are feeling today how to
shift the narrative yeah
I think we might put that in what to
watch if it happened let's see if they
become friends Amanda Forman thank you
very much she appreciate it uh the
documentary King Charles the boy who
walked alone is available now on
Paramount plus which is part of the same
company as CBS we are proud to say